so i have this number here and what i
would like you to do is pause this video
and tell me for this number
how many hundreds do we have how many
tens and how many ones pause this video
and try to think about it
all right well we can just look at each
of the place values and we could start
in either direction but let's start on
the right side so if we start on the
right we look at the ones place right
over here and this tells us that we have
two ones so we could write that right
over there and then we go to the next
place value we go one place to the left
we go to the tens place this tells us
how many tens we are dealing with and
this is four tens so we just we'd write
that like that and then last but not
least if we go one more place to the
left this is the hundreds place and so
we have eight hundredths
so this number which is
842
it's the same thing as 800s plus four
tens plus two ones or another way to
think about it is you could view it as
eight hundred
plus
four tens is the same thing as forty
plus
two ones is the same thing as two so
these are different ways of representing
the same number now what i just did up
here this is known as a place value
table which we will be discussing many
times as we start building our
understanding of place value so it's
good to know what people are talking
about when they say place value table so
let's just do one more example
let's say that we had the following
number
so this number
right over here and let's let's put that
into a place value table as well so how
many hundreds are am i dealing with how
many tens
and then how
many ones
pause this video again and see if you
can figure that out fill out this place
value table
all right
well we can see
that this is the number of hundreds
this is the number of tens because
that's the tens place and this is the
number of ones the ones place tens place
hundreds place and so if we start at the
left this time we have five hundreds
we see that right over there
we actually and this one's an
interesting example we have zero tens so
we'll just put a zero right over there
and we have seven ones so we put a seven
right over there